[Musique]
certaines études démontrent que plus de
10% des enfants qui fréquentent le
milieu se porter dans les associations
saurait atteindre des agressions ou des
violences sexuelles
donc c'est énorme l'objectif de cette
ppl c'est d'ouvrir le débat et surtout
d'envoyer un message fort aujourd'hui
les sportifs compris la parole les
médias relaient de partout ce phénomène
qu'on trouve dans le milieu sportif et
seul le parlement ne serait absente ce
débat c'est pas possible
[Musique]
la première c'est de permettre d'avoir
un contrôle sur les bénévoles qui
interviennent aujourd'hui dans le milieu
sportif
deuxième grand axe c'est l'information
la formation au niveau de l'éducation
nationale et des fédérations troisième
sujet c'est de d'alourdir les peines
aussi dans cette proposition c'est la
première condamnation que la personne
qui seraient condamnés ne pouvait plus
intervenir comme éducateur auprès des
jeunes enfants
c'est une haute responsabilité
aujourd'hui de d'enclencher une
procédure qui puisse d'abord condamné et
enrayer ce phénomène rassurer aussi des
parents protéger les enfants et les
clubs de sportifs
[Musique]